[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no place back
[Music]
a few moments later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys thank you for making it to the
end of the video as well thank you for
watch this video and a couple more thank
you so be saying that a lot in this next
minute or so I recently passed 19,000
subs and are really a close to being to
20k which is actually incredible and the
support on the last video the how-to
Shaolin is absolutely godlike right now
it's at like thirty nine thousand and
I'm recording the super elated nuts
about probably by the time I wake up
tomorrow morning which the day at this
video should go live it should be past
40k which is disgusting I did not expect
that to even get past like 15 I thought
this was just gonna be some dumb [ __ ]
and it wasn't gonna be worth it so I
stress for that like I said I didn't
expect the video to do good at all but
yeah I plan on doing tons more of these
obviously the one that you just saw now
the one before and tons including a
really big one dedicated to all of
marching fire that includes the voices
characters anything that regarding that
whole new update I'm going to be
covering the whole marching fire
experience is probably what I'm gonna
call it so look out for that roughly
around October one marching fire
releases cannot wait to get to that be a
guys discord in Twitter links in the
description if you want to join
definitely hop on on the disc over got a
lot of cool stuff in there
you guys if you guys haven't joined that
but yeah like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational sign up on or that being
balanced changes here all updates patch
notes leaks all that good [ __ ] some
gladiator gameplay and assuming videos
as you guys have seen recently yeah guys
sumo suits your videos would be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out with that guy so very very sturdy
thick bars in the video and peace out
[Music]